welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is James Scott Stirling professor of
political science professor of
anthropology and co-director of the
agrarian Studies program at Yale
University the author of several books
including seeing like a state professor
Scott's research concerns political
economy comparative agrarian societies
peasant politics Southeast Asia theories
of class relations and anarchism today
we'll talk with Professor Scott about
his newest book the art of not being
governed it's the first ever examination
of the volumes of literature on state
making that evaluates why people would
deliberately remain stateless welcome
professor Scott happy to be here let's
begin with an overview of your book tell
us about it
the book is a study of perhaps 100
million people who live in the Highland
areas between Southeast Asia China and
India so this is an area above Oh 200
250 meters in the highlands of Vietnam
all of Laos little corner of Cambodia
northern Thailand northern Burma the
southern large southern provinces of
China Yunnan guanxi and Guo Jo and also
northeastern India and these are this is
an area where I argue these hundred
million or so people who speak many
different languages who belong to many
different ethnic groups they are often
seen as primitive people who have always
stayed who have never been in a sense
touched by States my argument is that
these people for the last two thousand
years have been running away from States
from taxes from disease from Wars from
conscription and overtime they had
moved into the hills as states have
displaced them the Chinese stayed in
particular and that they have become
ethnic groups in the hills so they're
not primitive people there are people
who have chosen to move to the hills and
stay in the hills in order to avoid the
inconvenience of being incorporated as a
state how did you come to write the book
what gave you the idea well I've always
I'm a Southeast Asian so I work on
Southeast Asia in particularly Malaysia
and now I'm working on Burma and I began
being interested in the in the minority
ethnic groups of Burma which are 30% of
the country and which have conducted
rebellions against the Burmese
government for the last 40 or 50 years
they're the longest rebellions in a
sense in the modern in the modern world
and as you probably know on the seventh
of November Burma is holding largely
fake elections and so I originally
became interested in this in trying to
understand the deep history of Burmese
politics the relationship between the
valley people and the hill people that's
the way people think in Southeast Asia
and so this got to be larger than that
and got to be a deep history of the hill
people in general throughout Southeast
Asia and tell us about your methodology
how did you do the research it seems
like it would be fairly difficult given
this the span the geography well in the
past I have although I'm trained as a
political scientist I actually work more
like an anthropologist so I have spent a
couple of years living in it in a malay
village and I have spent a fair amount
of time in the hills of Burma it's
impossible to do research in Burma to
get a research visa but you can do a
fair amount of informal research by
simply trekking in the hills so I've
done a little bit of that but largely
the book is an effort to canvass the
literature everything we know about all
these groups throughout the hills how
they came to be there some of the some
of these groups you probably are
familiar with
the Hmong or Miao people who are you
could large numbers or refugees because
they work for the CIA
in Laos many of these people in
California some of them in Minneapolis
some of them in Providence some of them
in North Carolina
and so I picked the major ethnic groups
and then did a survey of their folklore
of their agriculture of their histories
and what we know about their movements
historically and in your book you you
talk about the somya who are the people
of zou Mia as Oh Mia is just a word a
it's not my word a Dutch scholar with
whom I've worked he invented the terms
Oh Mia so there's a place called Mizoram
in northeastern India and zou happens to
mean he'll or some people believe it
means a place far from the center and so
since this is in a sense and mountain
region far from States this is a as I
said this area is an area of a hundred
million people but it is it runs through
the borders of eight different nation
states Burma Thailand China India and so
on and it's the periphery of all of them
and so my colleague vilem van Schendel
he thought that we should not have area
studies that are concerned with just
Southeast Asia or with a nation we
should think of zones that have nothing
to do with States so these are people in
a sense who have a lot in common with
one another by not being a part of
States and we should study this group as
a whole and he proposed that we have
institutes and conferences onso Mian
studies and he invented the word as a
way of describing this both of the
geography of this area this mountain
zone and the people who live there tell
us about some of the findings in your
book well I can tell you about two
findings that might or three findings
that might be interesting the first one
is that I regard this area as what some
story ins call a shatter zone that is to
say it's an area where people who were
fleeing states and conscription and
taxes and famines and war they moved
away from States in order to be safer
and all these early states were also
slaving States so they moved away in
order to avoid becoming slaves being
captured as slaves into remote areas and
so that's one reason why these areas are
incredibly complicated ethnically and
linguistically because they're a shadow
zone of the little shards of States and
people who moved away from different
areas at different times who bump up
into one another and so on so at first
finding is that it's a shadow zone of
people who have moved away in the last
1500 years 2000 years it's a long deep
history the other thing is that they
practice what is called slash-and-burn
agriculture or fire field agriculture in
which a part of the forest is burned and
then crops are planted and after three
or four years another area of the forest
is burned it turns out to be very
ecologically responsible if you have a
lot of forest land to use because you
only come back to the same area after
half a century or something like that
and my argument is that the reason these
people they have a choice they could
plant wet rice and paddy Rice's we're
familiar with or they could plant this
rice this they could plant the root
crops that are characteristic of
slash-and-burn agriculture the reason
they plant the way they do is because
it's the kind of crops that the state
can never seize that is if you're
growing rice the state comes in and your
rice all gets ripe at the same time it
can take all your rice if you put it in
the ground early it can take all the
grain and then you're you're toast as
we'd say but if you plant root crops
like potatoes or cassava and so on if
the state wants your cassava they have
to dig it up tuber by tuber and you can
leave it in the ground for two or three
years and it's still good to eat so my
argument is that the agriculture these
people practice is not a primitive
agriculture
although it's often seen that way but
it's an agriculture that they have
chosen politically in order to make it
impossible for states to seize taxes
from them and to live in a dispersed way
that makes it hard for them to be taken
as slaves
the last finding that's that I don't
have a lot of evidence for but I want
people to think hard about is that these
people are almost all have oral cultures
rather than texts and literacy in the
modern sense and so they're seen as
backward in this respect as well and I
argue that we ought to at least hold
open the possibility that these people
once lived in valleys and we're pretty
sure that they had a literate minority
just like the Chinese and Berman's had
and when they moved to the hills they
decided to leave the texts and the
literacy behind because having an oral
culture is much more flexible you can
change the story about who you are you
are your genealogy your where are you
the history of your movements and I
argue that it's much more advantageous
for people who are weak and on the run
as it were to have an oral culture
rather than to have a written text in
which the written text stays in its
original form forever and you can refer
to it and you can see whether it's it
deviates or not but in oral culture
people the bards of these groups they
tell a story of the history and we know
that this there the story that the bards
tell change over time
and so you can if you have bards and an
oral culture you can tell a traditional
story that can gradually move in
conformity with the circumstances you
face and you can't do that with a
written text sure and what is the
conclusion you reach in the book well
the conclusion is that this is the
largest area of people in the world who
have not yet been incorporated
two states and this world is in a sense
it's a it's time is ending as things
like roads helicopters forms of modern
communication and so on make it possible
for the states of Southeast Asia and of
China to project their power and to
actually rule these people directly but
until now they've stayed out out of the
grips of states and you know if we look
at this in a long historical time we as
a species Homo sapiens have been around
for about 200,000 years the first states
were invented five or six or seven
thousand years ago and we'll long with
grain cultivation so that's very new
that's the last sort of minute right of
our time on earth and those states were
very very very small so historically
most people have lived outside States in
the long history of Homo sapiens and
it's only in the last five minutes so to
speak of our if we think of our whole
time here as a day that the states have
arisen and so these are kind of the last
remnants of people who tried to stay out
of the grip of states Eskimos or Inuit
are the same we can identify an area in
Africa where people run away from the
slave trade the North Atlantic slave
trade in the Arab slave trade and so on
and that's a kind of zone that's like a
shadow zone as well as own of refuge
where people run we can find places in
Brazil and in Latin America where people
rent to the hills so these places are
all over the world
the Berbers would be another example in
North Africa
so non-state peoples are were once a
majority of mankind and now they're a
diminishing minority but it's a history
of the relationship between States and
people who lived outside States what are
some of the universal characteristics
that you've come across in researching
the peoples of all of these different
in terms of why they would choose to
remain stateless or away from the rest
of society it's a good question
the in Southeast Asia and Africa in
particular and in Latin America also the
problem of the early States was holding
people at the center that is to say if
you're a state you need to have grain
and people concentrated in a small area
so you can conscription army so you can
have the surplus grain that every state
has a lot of people who are not growing
grain who are living off the grain that
other people produce and given
pre-modern conditions of transportation
that grain and those people have to be
in a small area for example a bullock
cart carrying grain if it goes 150 miles
the Bullock's will have eaten all the
grain that they can possibly carry in
the back of the cart so a traditional
state can only extend its power
successfully for about 150 miles or so
unless they have a river which makes it
easier to move faster and so on so the
problem of the traditional state was
holding people in so that they could use
their labor and they could grab surplus
grain people who lived outside the state
didn't have to pay taxes and we're not
subject to a conscription and were not
troubled by large-scale Wars which are a
characteristic of states right States
make Wars Wars make states and so there
were lots of Vantage's of living outside
the state over time sometimes people
move toward the state or were taken as
slaves and and located at the center of
the state but when states got into
trouble and there were famines and Wars
people leaked back and went to the hills
and they went to areas where it's hard
for the state to find them okay and
final question what was the most
surprising thing you found in doing your
research for the book
I think that the thing that's surprising
about the book as a whole
and the reason I think why it's a gotten
a fair amount of attention is because
most people think that everyone who
lives outside the state is some
Neolithic Stone Age survival who have
not invented modern agriculture who
haven't invented iron tools and so on
they're seen as people who are savages
primitives and not yet
not in a sense not yet civilize my
argument is that these people were part
of civilized Valley States and over time
they moved away from these states in
order to escape the inconveniences of
civilizations right because
civilizations mean States they mean once
you crowd people into a small area you
have domesticated animals and you all
have you have the fleas and ticks and
rats and mice that feed on the grain and
all of our zoonotic diseases are
diseases that move between domesticated
animals and human beings
so the valley early valley states with
this concentration of people
domesticated animals and grain we're
also unhealthy if we find skeletons of
the same period of time in which one
group is hunter-gatherers and the other
are living inside grain States the
hunter and gatherers skeletons are
larger there are they they're taller and
their bones show less evidence of
disease whereas the people living in
States are their skeletal remains are
smaller and their bones show a lot more
evidence of disease so we have a lot of
evidence that it was not healthy to live
in early States not to mention the
question of taxes and conscription very
good thank you very much for being here
today and sharing some of your research
thank you
good for more information about
professor Scott and his work please
visit our website at yale.edu backslash
macmillan report be sure to join us
again for another episode
of the Macmillan report made possible
through funding from the Whitney and
Betty Macmillan Center for International
and area studies at Yale